so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys I'm hyped today I'm
still tonight I'm super stoked my name
is Thomas dobachiola whatever you want
to call me this is the dope as usual
podcast this is my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up guys what's up guys we're
custom we're going hard we might bleep
it to stay on YouTube's good side but
here we are guys this episode me and
Marty what two seconds before we started
guest episodes you said was like a
presentation for school like be prepped
be ready yo the sub's gone not even this
there's a sub the sub went to the
bathroom yeah we're chilling do whatever
you want you could sell stuff that's
pretty much what these episodes are I'm
excited guys I'm really hyped we have a
lot of good news a lot of good stuff
happening just the most stuff on Earth
happening all at once some of the most
insane stuff of all time in-house
actually going down budget dope stuff
also this is the first time Marty did
all the I don't know what's coming up
today usually I'm like yo Mario wanna
talk about this you're like okay I got a
few topics and then we mix and we have
an episode today Marty wrote them all on
and went let's go with what you've got
and you tell me so this is this is like
a we're gonna try try something new
today but we just want to hang out with
you guys I'm hyped today it's what's
Friday night yeah it's Friday night it's
like 11 o'clock at night we're gonna
bust this out guys this is gonna be fun
the solo episode we have guest after
guest after guest coming up so this is
the you know our little get together a
ketchup nice catch-up episode it was
supposed to be Jaleel but he actually
had his wisdom teeth out so yes wisdom
teeth that we're gonna be next next week
we'll let you recuperate don't don't
come with your mouth cut open it's cool
he's like we'll be coming a couple days
later like hell no just wait a week then
come in so that's what we're doing right
now and also right off the bat let's do
it right now if you have any questions
for the artist Jaleel drop them in the
comments yes drop in the comments we do
up to the first thousand Rocco's
actually right here today Rocco helps
with us with all the comments so he's
here he's here right now so Jaleel the
artist a musician we usually ask this on
dope as usual podcast Instagram we'll
ask you what do you want want to do if
you could ask a question for this artist
what would it be we're doing that on
YouTube today so if you have any
questions you want to ask drop it in the
comments we'll go through them and you
might see your question pop up with
Jaleel next week
all right let's go I hope he got all his
wisdom teeth taken out
filthy back when I was a 17 year old boy
what do you mean they only took out
three of them me too I have one left but
that other one was still coming down
and when I was driving home from the
episode uh Mom episode part what like
half my tooth fell out
you didn't tell me this yeah
yeah what yeah I was like something
weird's going on with my two let's go to
Eastern Dental well no I go to no Dental
because April's like whoa you gotta wait
till September we'll get some denim what
no just pay for it yeah I know that's
what I was thinking she's like no you're
good it'll be fine but come to find out
I mean my wisdom tooth is actually
coming down and pushing out my back
molar baller so it like knocked out like
half of it it didn't really do what I
want so I'll just ludicrous tooth
I don't know about that move get out the
way oh I really thought you were gonna
get that one already I had so much
which album which what are we doing here
Southern Hospitality no no yeah so
anyway I rocked that half a tooth for a
minute
the rest of that [ __ ] popped out before
[ __ ] September rolled around so fell
out on its own yes natural all right
yeah it's not the 1600s yeah I know I
know it's Ireland
from Ireland we're not saying Irish
Irish people don't have dental insurance
that's not what we're saying it's Irish
yeah it's not the 1600s yeah not cool
though I'm like no no you guys were in
there take out all four of them what are
we doing
um David tell you what happened with me
did they just pull him out
or did they break them into pieces and
scoop them out
no I'm pretty sure they just mine
crumbled into pieces he snapped it and
looked at me and I'm like sounded bad
your wisdom teeth yeah they broke them
down and then scoop you were awake yeah
what
Western Dental that could be the problem
Western Dental that's why I say oh you
went to Eastern Dental it's the ghetto
like oh my mom is a single mother
no the guy only comes in once a month
and does everyone's in one day I was
like number 30 in line to get my teeth
pulled out and as he's doing it I'm
pushing my jaw back I'm like stop stop
you're gonna break it I can feel my jaw
about the
feel the pressure like no no stop stop
and I I held it like this while he broke
it because I was so afraid that he's
like I've never broken anyone's jaw and
told him I feel it it's gonna come off
stop stop pressing that heart on my face
I got kind of upset and he looked at me
like do you want me to do it go yeah can
I at least hold my chin just do whatever
you want to do and I had my earphones in
my earpod uh my iPod I made a Beatles
playlist and try to space out didn't
help at all and as he's breaking it I
can hear it crumble like break and he
shows me after just pieces and he Scoops
the bottom out I'm sure somebody out
there in the comments has had that
happen dentist I've had bad luck man
Jesus Christ it didn't hurt it hurt the
jaw it felt like it was gonna wait weird
wisdom teeth like showing through or no
no they sliced it they cut me and then
pulled them and what broke them awake
for that [ __ ] everyone was you just get
the you just get the shots numbs you
that's it yeah
no dude Mr Dental they don't have time
there's the waiting room and on the
other side of the wall is where
everybody's getting their teeth inside
my mouth and I'm just looking at you and
chat yeah that was awkward bro it was
very weird they're crunching I could
hear it that's the only thing that
sucked is I can hear
and he's like do you want to see it at
the end and I saw shards of my teeth it
was disgusting like
yes yes but the inside of teeth it looks
exactly like you would think hmm just
like the outside but whiter that's it
with blood in it it's crazy dude I saw
my teeth chunks and was like
yeah the most horrifying disgusting
feeling in life is biting down as you're
chewing and realizing you just crunched
a tooth I've never felt that me neither
until the second half of the [ __ ]
came out
nah why do we talk why did this happen
what are we
oh Jaleel you got your teeth
yo we can't talk we can't talk about
certain things because we'll never just
come back
um I'm interested in looking doing my
little research and looking more into
like his whole story and everything I
don't know from what I've been the first
time I ever saw him was a tick tock and
I went he does have the oddest build
I've ever seen on human and then I saw
another one who goes oh he's an artist
and I saw him doing the back flip off
like 20 feet and Landing like a like an
anime character who is this he's like
Francis and ganu says
it feels like he punched through a tree
it's crazy bro he looks like a beast and
I saw and I go oh he's an artist and
then everyone's like you should get
Jalil then we told Malcolm can you get
Jaleel for us because everybody's asking
for him castilo mentioned him he
mentioned him too yeah he mentioned him
too I just saw a video from crowd
surfing and he was just too big he went
on and they all tipped over and [ __ ]
yo that's a good problem to have man
like you don't like my music
I'm not for real guys I'm kidding but
it's a good look it's gonna be
interesting I'm looking forward to that
episode
um yeah I'm excited I'm excited to hear
what he's got to say like we haven't
researched fully so
it's gonna be fun you guys made that one
happen all right you guys did that you
guys always non-stop ask me my DMs like
you should get your Leo Julia white like
oh it's an artist and then I saw like
that's the guy from Tick Tock even if we
don't respond all the suggestions are
always like we really try to make note
of them and think about them add them to
the list it's been so amazing to be
working with malca amazing like it's
been so fun and exciting every time my
little slack notification goes off
because it's like you don't know what
they're gonna say I know we can't say
everything but no we they've been
throwing just well every morning you
text me go shut up every time I get it
Go Rosie
shut up who they hit up who said they're
coming oh my god really cool it's not
just two potheads anymore going hey
would you like to come on our show yeah
it's really nice to have like just all
the slots kind of filling up and have
like a real professional high-level team
handling it it's just great it's what
the show deserves it's how it's the only
way to keep leveling up and it's it's
really exciting to see it happen and
just the fact that they're so excited to
be making it happen I can feel that
perfect perfect segue
perfect segue into them there's an extra
little topic real quick but we're gonna
go to number two okay yeah no go right
ahead this is all you now mind you I
didn't know anything about this next
topic
but once I realized I just knew it
became a priority that we had to make
this happen
so I let Malkin know like we need to
make this happen and they went not only
did they make it happen but they did us
one better
oh my God the first time I ever heard
this artist my friend do shout out to
Deuce he lives in Sacramento first time
he told me about this group and I what I
used to do I did not I didn't have lime
wire and stuff we're at 10 minutes we're
10 minutes okay I didn't have LimeWire
so what I would do is street light
record Santa Cruz shout out to
Streetlight records in Santa Cruz my
homie Ralph used to help manage that my
sister used to work there that's why I
went to all the shows at Catalyst met
all these rappers and stuff because I
was the little brother that actually was
a fan so they're like yo this will
actually listen to me he's got all your
albums come up to the front you don't
have a brother why did you get limewear
I never know I said I never had it so
the reason the way I would listen to
music I'd go to Streetlight buy a new
record an album and see if I like that
Banner artist
and I would listen it front to back
while looking at the cover art
every that's how I listen to music or if
I'm by myself smoke mad joints
not driving and listen to music and
that's how I would that's how I break in
every album and as soon as it finishes I
go didn't hit me that hard I'm gonna
have to do it again boom play it again
just to see if I like if I bump it twice
and I'm not great it's not a great album
to me
were you deep into music before you
started smoking or did yeah my whole
life I was a little kid like you'd zone
out pre-weed yeah um my favorite thing
on Earth because I'm Insomniac you
remember waking up Now That's What I
Call Music but do you remember the other
ones would be like an old member of
whatever band with the new young girl
well in the 60s we did this yeah when I
started this band and you always tell
the old guys like get away from me the
girl that was introducing him he's like
and then the the names of the songs You
Remember by Ram Jam this name and they
play eight seconds of that clip that's
how I learned bands as a kid that's how
I fell in love with classic rock because
the classic rock with Roger Daltrey he
was the guy on it anyway I used to watch
it every night it would be the same
information for like four years straight
that's how I found out about classic
rock and I would uh put him on the
internet and then I found LimeWire which
I didn't know how to really do it I had
my friend help me and that's when I
started how to do it but that was like
14 15. before that I was just asking my
grandma my grandpa
how do I find this music and my grandpa
watched doo-wop concerts on TV all the
time so that's how I started liking
doo-wop and Motown that's why I have all
those box sets and stuff because you
would think you grew up next to a
[ __ ] Bodega that slang the hottest
underground mixtapes because you're more
knowledge of money underground hip-hop
alone aside from everything else that's
13 and up it's so deep like you you
could do a whole we could do a whole
episode on just underground hip-hop [ __ ]
that 99 of people don't know about that
was the thing that my friends would burn
CDs I would borrow them so I wasn't like
super like I had like Jedi Mind Tricks
great uh Immortal Technique all that
type of stuff uh oh man I'm doing myself
but I wasn't like super underground rap
like that I didn't like anything on the
radio because I didn't you know what
this is really what it is
when I'm at school and I hear somebody
being ignorant and dumb whether it is
they're they're a nice person or not
when I hear and I go
get away from me they might be a nice
person but I'm an [ __ ] I think
and I'm like you like what that's your
favorite band
oh follow the [ __ ] with you that's your
favorite band not to their face that's
mean yeah but in my head I'm like
I judge you differently now that's your
favorite artist that's whack you know
stuff like that that's your favorite
movie things like that so when it came
to that and I heard that say that girl's
annoying me and she's like well Trey
Songz and Nellie's my favorite Artistry
well now I do not listen to that that's
what you like I don't want to be a part
of it I love Nelly Nelly is awesome but
I'm saying that's how it started for me
and how I went anti-mainstream would not
listen to it then I realized I was an
ignorant [ __ ]
mainstream artists were underground to
begin with and they got so popping that
now their mainstream I was an ignorant
hey now there was a time in the 90s and
2000s where there was like the record
exec that just found him oh yes yes like
no but then you had DMX who was just DMX
mainstream to me never listened to him
only my mom because I was like always on
the radio on TV I'm cool you'll never
get that again crazy huh because think
about it you'll never get somebody that
authentic because like DMX for instance
everybody coming up they didn't have any
sort of periscope out to the outside
world they were just them in their
little existence all they knew like no
real so much awareness that the internet
brought about like I don't know that's a
weird crossover generation of
pre-internet to current where as far as
an artist goes because now you're
influenced by everything I know about
coming up so I'm aware of so much more
now outside of my own reality yeah you
know like it's just it's hard to explain
but it's just
somebody like him as an example coming
up in his story uh I don't know if I
don't know I don't know if we get that
again that originality
I don't know there's a lot of artists
out there I think you would like a lot I
need to make a playlist you put me onto
one oh yeah so oh back we're oh we are
off track
first time I ever heard this artist
about these CDs from
street light
went home it was like day six into
living my apartment with jeebus the
first apartment I ever had you know what
I mean me and him yeah I had a spot with
my grandpa when he moved down I had the
house but I was underage and have a car
I was still going to school it was trash
I put my headphones in
put my iPod on I mean put the mute no no
I bought the CDs that's right and then I
finally figured out someone to put it on
my iPod so I could listen to it in my
headphones but what I did is I put the
CD player on
and I listened to this album
[ __ ] fell in love with this music and
I couldn't believe I never heard it
before
and that wasn't
in 2008
damn
2008 yeah
so I'm talking about atmosphere my
favorite rapper of all time is Slug I
mean I'm not saying we're atmosphere
rapper because that's a group but slug
of atmosphere is my favorite rapper of
all [ __ ] time you guys know that I
talk about it constantly I love that
fool's music so [ __ ] much
favorite artist of all time
so when I was in Indiana Chicago oh no
no when I was I wasn't Indiana I was in
Chicago I was at the breakfast spot if
you watched the
if you watch the Vlog when I was looking
check out this breakfast two seconds
after we stopped filming this full text
me a [ __ ] screenshot from Malcolm
media and I almost shed a [ __ ] tear I
screamed as loud as I could in the
restaurant like no [ __ ] what what
screamed bro
[ __ ] booked them
what
they're coming on the show guys
I
I
don't
I don't remember where I was on my first
birthday but that's how I feel I don't
remember that's how I feel like
personal win the personal victory
let's go my favorite artist of all time
bro
you got the albums hanging up in your
house
I've been to every atmosphere show every
minute was alone I told you that and
said this last one
I've gone by myself to everyone because
nobody was ready to go and go I'm not
[ __ ] missing it I went to the Red
Rocks I mean I went to the Greek Theater
by myself went to the
Santa Cruz Auditorium one by myself and
one more by myself I remember Byron
sitting in the back like I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't have direction to get home
I don't have [ __ ] GPS at this time it
was like 2008 I remember I had to
[ __ ] call homies on the way home to
get myself home bro I was so [ __ ]
lost from Berkeley I had no idea to get
back took my three and a half hours but
I don't give a [ __ ]
atmosphere as my favorite group
so
atmosphere's booked all right they were
booked for a couple days ago then as
real quick recap manager hit us up and
go hey we realized we booked him the
same day as the show he could not be
talking on interview the day before the
show for his voice we're like oh my God
no I mean it's okay I'm just Juiced then
what two days later he goes hey slug
would like invite you and Marty out to
the show said the show's gonna be on or
and the podcast is awesome can't wait to
come on the show when they come back to
LA
ah and he says by the way here's some
tickets come to the show let's go so
this fool my favorite artist in the all
time left is [ __ ] tickets at the box
office and I didn't do [ __ ] his [ __ ]
tear so that's why we went to the
atmosphere show the other day and I I
don't know if I filmed anything I just
stared the whole time like this is some
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it was awesome we all
went on it was like a big ass group it
was great yeah because the last only
times I ever seen was live band and they
play they play more like alternative to
songs I mean a lot of the songs they
play but they play with a live band and
[ __ ] I love the hip-hop [ __ ] from them
so when I saw him come out with ant Slug
and then they had another DJ there like
this is a hip-hop show oh my [ __ ] god
dude I I was so Juiced I was so Juiced
and then what happened yo if you listen
underground you're gonna be hyped as
we're leaving my homies like hey grouch
is right there go shut the [ __ ] up
Crouch is from The Living Legends a
[ __ ] amazing ass rapper and I saw him
and go oh my God it is [ __ ] the only
time I ever saw him in person I was 15
and he walked by The Catalyst I was like
oh holy [ __ ] I like lost my [ __ ] in my
hair I am in my 30s same thing
I got a picture with him this time
though she wanted all that [ __ ] like
jeebus he put me into Living Legends my
friend Jeeves I remember I looked in his
wall and there was a group a poster of
so many artists go what is Living
Legends
he goes dude they're a group of artists
all this [ __ ] another quick story Living
Legends got nine [ __ ] in it I
think or seven
Sunspot Jones and lucky I am they came
to Merced one time quick story I don't
think I ever told the story The Kingdom
Merced went to a little bar could fit
about 30 fools in there and they rocked
the [ __ ] out of it right I'm strong
we know that I can mention a lot for
being fat and out of shape
I was rocked out back then I was in
shape when I was like 19. I was pretty
[ __ ] ripped still like I was big
the reason I say this Sunspot lucky I am
playing their show Sunspot Jones is on
stage and he's crouching on the little
stage that's how small this venue is
he's like almost crouching because he's
not tall enough to stand on the stage
he's singing his song I'm like every
[ __ ] word I'm all hyped and he sees
me and I see him see me it's a small
crowd he's doing it he looks at me and
he just does one of these
and I just finished the whole verse shut
up oh no like
like one bar of it I was do and then he
joined in and he was just like [ __ ] he
was like slap my shoulder and everybody
got back up and started singing all my
homies like were like
because we're all hands bro we're fans
of the underground then Sunspot Jones
aside to Stage dive
and crushed like three people
drove and crushed this girl in two dudes
they could not hold him up
then you heard lucky start crackling
laughing while he was doing his verse
like oh [ __ ] this Fool's on the ground
he gets back up he's like [ __ ] man
damn he starts wrapping his purse and
then like 20 minutes later the reason I
brought the strong thing this
[ __ ] stage Dives
right at me like hip out though not flat
hip out I [ __ ] caught him on my chest
Marty like this four year old man and
Anthony's next to me like that
and the stage is only right here and I
go like this and I like throw him
straight and he does this what the [ __ ]
and looks back down at me and then all
my homies are looking at me like Thomas
you're the [ __ ] man like a
single-handedly caught the whole whole
body of this man
and it's like stood him back up and I
thought like bro you got to be careful
stage diving what if I couldn't take it
you're folding in half dead scorpioning
oh I'm all hyped up and sweat right now
thinking about that [ __ ] dude every time
I tell stories they get me hyped I
actually physically start getting my
yeah
anyway stage diving is a [ __ ] risk
yeah it is it is ask Omar ratchet man
how many killed those kids in Idaho he
landed on four bodies
um sorry
how would you describe atmosphere as
music to somebody that was President I
was trying to describe it to you you
were actually really
it's interesting well you described
their like family fan base I was like oh
it's like this no it's not like that
it's stronger no it's like it's like
this artist no the atmosphere's fan base
is more cult and with us yeah our fans
like yo everyone's just happy to be here
and smiling I've never felt that type of
energy at any at the show
how enthusiastically they were singing
all the bars like like really meaning it
like the vast majority of the people in
there it was just different everybody
wasn't all cool like there were it was
different I've never seen it I don't
know it was like so different than a
regular rap show
but homeboy is like
50 like 51 yeah out there crushing it
crashing it huh so stoked I'm so happy
I'm so excited that they're coming so
it's postponed and their next LA cycle
is in January
so let's just say this guys we got
atmosphere coming on this [ __ ] show
do you feel like you know a lot about
his life
only through the lyrics
like I probably know all the words to
all the albums I have do you already
know what I'm gonna ask yeah no
interesting a lot of the things I I the
reason is he's born in September 7th I'm
born September 6th a lot of the [ __ ] he
says I go I relate to this so heavily
and I found his birthday go oh maybe
these guys were like kind of the same
date is that why I think the same some
of the lyrics I he's that this
[ __ ] says to go bro yep dead on
that's how I feel too and you know when
you connect with them like when right
now I might say something yeah me too
man same thing same thing the same thing
it's like a connection of hey I [ __ ]
with you that's what I realized when I
put out the CD CD when I put out Massive
Action hold up uh
just went out I don't know but it's out
yeah that is
um was that I'm like oh I'm just kind of
repurposing the same message that we
talked about through the [ __ ] yeah
through the music music
positivity and crushing it that's my
that's what that's what the whole show's
about
um but while Marty's moving this camera
quick in January we'll never have to do
that again I mean I've got a team of
eight doing the cameras over there at
Malcolm media
um guys I know I'm sweating and I'm
dying over here but I'm excited my
favorite [ __ ] artist guys you guys
know that I you and if you know me
personally and you're gonna text me go
Thomas what the [ __ ] I remember going to
the show The Lyric he has now all my
friends are famous it's either one thing
or another that [ __ ] stuck to me when I
was like 18 I go one day I'm gonna do
something where my friends are the
people I look up to and like people I
see in movies and listen to and it's
like
it's so weird what your brain what
happens and what you remember I remember
what I was doing when I said that like
you know what
me too man one day some of my homies are
gonna be like famous fools I'm gonna be
doing something super sick where I could
work with them in some way and it's this
and who would have thought bro who would
have thought Marty come on man come one
day Adam Sandler's gonna be sitting
right across from us
oh can we
all right well we're not saying anything
all right but
working on it I know guys this is a
crazy episode I know working on it right
now Adam Sandler holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I
almost shed it to you for real when you
told me that one
the One You're Gonna Be hyped
yeah so we're gonna have sailing right
now guys I didn't want to say it but I
guess we're saying it yeah also uh in
New York I'll be there next week and I'm
going to see Adam Sandler live in
concert
what a trip I'm so excited but yeah um
all in all guys I know we're starting
dragging this out again I'm just very
excited let's get on to the next topic
but either way
atmospheres booked they're coming on
this [ __ ] show
thank you thank you guys for making that
possible I am so Juiced and hyped and
excited and stoked thank you
um
that's I'm most excited about honestly
I'm just so [ __ ] stoked dude I'm I'm
I'm I mean like
that's your DMX for me yeah bro what who
am I in the room [ __ ] right now we're
gonna have to book a uh a medium so oh
my cousin my cousin said that well my
cousin William's a fool he goes you know
what you should do hire a medium so you
can have an episode with one of your
favorite artists that passed away stop
it
don't do that they're perfecting
families are going to be so upset also
how hard would it be like yo DMS need to
ask you a question man for real as a fan
from a child come on but that that's the
dumbest idea that's the most
disrespectful [ __ ] I've ever heard we're
not really gonna do it guys but my
cousin's like you should just introduce
the media I'm just like nah bro
it would be amazing if that could be
that Tupac
so what's the beef about 25 years later
we get the answer like oh man I'd like
I'd like to get Dr Dre on he's never
done a podcast I don't think I could be
wrong
no I've never seen them they did an
apple show Dr Dre DJ poo and like I
think Ansley or I can't remember Apple
show but I think Rock and push trees on
there so you ever see that show oh [ __ ]
DJ Poo's rocking all of it I had to find
some [ __ ] to Apple to say that I'm
allowed to that they're allowed to use
it
I ever told you that no yeah so the
whatever show that is
just organically yeah yeah I gave him
some [ __ ] I saw him go
DJ who's a [ __ ] man dude I never even
asked him to wear his game some [ __ ] and
he [ __ ] wore it on the show that
Apple hit me up this is your logo we
found out from a certain person that
needs to contact you for push tree you
trademark oh Jesus yes
not hyped
but out of this next piece of
information
let's get it big you guys really excited
why is it so hot I'm excited that's why
I'm all hyped and moving around and [ __ ]
you guys ready
the dope is Yola Channel on YouTube Hold
Up Hold on hold on I'm sorry let me we
gotta this is like
let's just take a second here hold on
first of all when you walk back in we
heard the
oh yeah we heard our friend he's in the
warehouse right now when we went to film
right now I'm like yo The Crickets back
it's been a whole season I haven't heard
him okay I'm sorry here we go
foreign
channel is now 100 back in the good
graces of YouTube and monetized
the [ __ ] with a thought we'd ever see
this day come
just out of nowhere what
hold on yeah we gotta bring that back
real quick what did you do because the
old channel is an YouTube partner and is
monetized
do we feel like this is related to that
Biden tweet
I don't know but I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah how ironic
I'll just you know what this means
I'm not a shadow band they actually show
my videos
I was blacklisted bad
like probably the most I would say the
most except I mean I didn't delete it
too so it's not like yeah it's not just
everyone else like I've been deleted
just as of hours ago we just premiered
basically a test video
hey guys
just think of YouTube's for real and
guess what
no age restriction and it was said do
you want to monetize this uh this video
and I put yes
how long has it been since you've had a
non-age restricted video on Adobe Zola
Channel
they're here and there but more than one
2019.
damn I've been getting my view [ __ ] on
for over three years
a district is not just oh they're not
showing you no it's they killed the
views bro
they crush the [ __ ] views like so bad
and it's not all about the views but
when it comes to the views of us putting
in five bands to make a video and the
views are 25 000 views when I have a
million Subs like dude this isn't fair
two months later I get 30 comments I
didn't even know you did this like I
know you didn't you know when people DM
me like bro I haven't seen you post in
months like bro I post every [ __ ]
week the same time you just don't know
and it wasn't all just so easy though
like
your [ __ ] was glitching while they were
like so this is
no this ABS I was going to sleep
somebody goes all your videos are gone I
went on YouTube and all my videos are
gone
but when I logged in they're all there
and then when I refreshed they popped up
when I refreshed again they were gone
and I had about 700 messages when I woke
up this morning saying dude are you
serious no no and I went no did they
take they deleted the channel after they
monetized they were like they would do
that [ __ ] that's what I was thinking
and I looked I go no no just glitch and
as of about an hour ago we're back
but psychological world oh it scared me
it definitely scared me to death I'd
even tell you my original Instagram
my guy hit me up you recovered it he's
in just can't get it to be unlocked
but my original Instagram
is recovered
original one the first one that had all
my first
works of art nug toy pictures all the
dope that show that one with all the
famous ass fools were following it did
you lose all those images you made yeah
because I I never backed up my phone I
was a drug dealer so like how many I
just had a [ __ ] phone I'm gonna be
talking like 100 like what other
graphics and [ __ ] that you made that
were lost oh 75 like so many
damn I have a lot of them but they're
screenshotted from Tumblr because
someone made a fake Tumblr account
posted all my content so I got my
content back so
that's
right
um so yeah so sorry dope is yellow
channel is officially on the YouTube
Partner program I cannot believe it now
how does this affect you going into how
you make your videos
I don't care about making money
so I'll just turn the monetization off
all I care about is when you're on
monetization program they don't restrict
you as much they don't flag you every
second it's definitely not about the
monetization I don't care about the
money at all you're so far there's
nobody more far in the red on a channel
no
like 20 bands a month already
yeah and that's that's like an
investment in other ways but still
nobody not a lot of people are willing
to do that
oh
yeah
I mean
that Yola channel gets money gets time
gets treated as if it is oh my god I
didn't even put an editing editing money
in my head oh oh and I mean you're going
out traveling and all that yeah I mean
it's a lot we had the set boat oh god I
didn't even think about the lights and
the sets and everything I was just
talking about the time yeah it's all a
write-off for a young entrepreneur but
still you gotta you are fronting that
cost like it pays off in other ways
because yes thank you for saying that
because he does [ __ ] those make me so
sad right now thinking about oh my God
how much money do I spend a month on
this I don't make no money oh that
investment sprouted off the podcast it
brought about the dope exactly like I
sell more shirts when they make a video
that's why I always replaced it brand
deals but it's like
apparently it's like an even it's the
tough road to doing it
I have seven companies because three
don't make any profit because I push it
right back into it push trees like I
make more clothes
prepaid me somehow please thank you
that'd be sick
um
could you imagine they back paid me
that's what I was like the other day I'm
thinking it's so amazing and so they
really did back pay me
um
but they actually wiped that clean on
the dash didn't they yeah when I went
into the monetization bank you got a
fresh start zero dot dot zero zero also
money sign in front of this afraid to
mentioned that
USD I was as I pressed my password went
press this and
ears
and press enter when
above my eyes and there's eight [ __ ]
figures right there
zeros oh [ __ ] I was like you know it's
okay it's okay how many times in life do
you have that moment
true
legitimately you could
it could there could have been a
scenario odd number of eight figures
thanks three what oh I only three almost
three something three point something
million dollars I never got but it's
okay who cares
we're here
no it's okay we're here that money is
gonna go someone needed it more than me
I guess [ __ ] dicks but it's okay I
don't give a [ __ ] because if I cared I
would die
I would [ __ ] die from frustration
you're gonna go down in the history
books of that [ __ ] that's what happens
it'll come back it'll come back to times
a hundred you two I'm calling it now
when this gets better
you just gonna pardon me in a very big
way
and I'm gonna make some [ __ ] money
off of it I I promise it's gonna be
double digit million dollars I maybe
even triple manifestation is real I know
this is coming I just don't know in
which way maybe when we go is Fairly
Legal and I run YouTube cannabis
corporate section
the cultural advisor what cultural like
swallow is YouTube's music cultural
advisor cannabis [ __ ] crush it oh
shout out by the way I didn't tell you
this but Beverly Hills tedx is booked
and oh [ __ ]
the date isn't out yet but he told me
Marty's doing a TED Talk Rocco yeah
another while I'll link that yeah put
the [ __ ] horns on yeah I mean come on
that just reminded me of it I just found
that out earlier because today they
asked me to go and do one in Miami and
I'm like all right you got one in SoCal
he's like bro you go we actually are
just finalizing Beverly Hills so I was
like let's let's do it I gotta
I wanted to move on to that after I did
the music and just so I had enough brain
space to like write my topic out and now
all I need in life is somebody to put a
date on something and it's like all
right I'll get it done so once they tell
me the date then I'll then I'll do what
I gotta do but that was like uh
a thing that wallow did how like he put
up a video how this free engagement made
me a million dollars
about how he did his tedx talk and then
from there he got so many like public
speaking engagements in that following
year he made over a million dollars but
it's not about that to me I just value
the opportunity so much you get paid to
public speak holy [ __ ] oh yeah I'm a
yellow [ __ ] pay me oh yeah you
know how [ __ ] fun yeah we want to
build that into the podcast tour oh
podcast tours gonna start off with
[ __ ] 10 to 15 minutes to stand up
this tour is gonna be me open mic in it
yeah
yeah we're trying to think of some
theatrics and [ __ ] bro it's booked I
mean it's ready it's they're picking out
the theater but it's going to be in
Beverly Hills they have the name for it
and stuff so already
she better wear a suit not for real but
you better look dull I can see it now
I'm probably gonna film the [ __ ] out of
it I know I know I'm just kidding I'm
probably gonna wear a bill shirt
it's the first starts off how about them
bills how about them [ __ ] bills
probably already know vpns are great for
protecting your privacy and security
online by hiding your IP address nordvpn
just to introduced a brand new feature
to the desktop apps that provides threat
protection takes your whole digital
security to a brand new level and it's
going to protect you from malware cyber
attackers Fishers schemers scammers
spammers you name it nordvpn app is
protecting you even if you aren't
connected to a VPN server if you ever
wake up and go Hey where's the Niner
game oh they're playing in Buffalo so
basically switch your virtual location
with nordvpn it allows you to watch the
sporting games that you wouldn't be able
to watch if you were in say the West
Coast nordvpn also enables its users to
watch Netflix categories that are
available outside of their country
nordvpn is the fastest VPN on the planet
no buffering no lagging while you're
streaming trying to watch something
nordvpn's the price of one cup of coffee
per month and can be used on up to six
different devices right now go to
nordvpn.com forward slash YOLO that's
our code Yola use that code you're going
to get a huge discount off your plan and
all above all four months for free right
off the bat four months for free with a
30 day money back guarantee
yo what's up guys thank you so much for
watching this episode and we just want
to take a quick moment to talk about one
of our sponsors and this is ship station
right now if you go to shipstation.com
and use our promo code dope as usual
you're gonna get 60 day free trial you
guys know Marty and I we're both small
business owners is what we've been doing
our whole adult lives essentially since
I moved to LA push trees has been with
ship station non-stop 100 every single
day it couldn't be easier Rosie and I
have had so many headaches before we
started from start to finish from the
moment the customer presses click to buy
something to the time it gets to you to
print to ship everything is done from
ship station Etsy Amazon eBay Shopify
all of that is perfectly integrated
Black Friday is next month guys get
ready if you're a small business owner
this is the lifeblood the foundation of
your whole fourth quarter is this right
here any company in history that's ever
used ship station for more than a year
has never left lifelong customers have
not gone anywhere 98 and that's over a
hundred and thirty thousand different
companies and then a lot of you that do
small businesses they always ask for
advice ship station is the thing that's
helped Rosie and I with push trees since
2015. for me e-commerce was using this
ship station made it very easy remember
dope as usual at checkout the promo code
and that's 60 days for free thank you so
much for watching and shout out to
shipstation for sponsoring this episode
I was just gonna
if you want to see Freddie Gibbs on
another [ __ ] podcast oh please tag
that full oh boy that we're gonna start
doing that you want to see a certain
person well you know if we want to see a
third person on the show malco's already
reached out to Freddie Gibbs but you
know Freddy G is one of our favorite
artists this this feels so hard and
funny and [ __ ] and that's what I want
him on the show for because that
[ __ ] is hysterical I notice he's
doing like zany's comedy oh like I don't
know if he's doing stand-up he could do
Stanton bro he's funny man hold on he's
funny dude
um but yeah go tag Freddie Gibbs but yo
we want to see on the dove as usual
podcast how'd that happen that's how we
got Stilo on here guys that wasn't uh
Malcolm media thing that was you a lot
of guys did that a lot of that 70 so far
has been because you guys tag them ask
them say hey come check out the show and
they check it out and go oh I like it
and then they come on the show so thank
you
so isn't that crazy so it's such a crazy
little cycle of a community tell YouTube
to pay me
[Music]
I swear to God
if YouTube back pay me because you guys
I would give every one of you a dollar
um
yeah you can do that I'll give every one
of you two dollars
every subscriber
give me two bucks
get a sign a million dollar bills
no that's a Stamper yeah I'm not gonna
sign a million things I signed 400 at
the end of anything in my room I felt
bro and I print yeah slowly
slowly so I'm like uh would you guys be
mad if you just did a quick Yola I don't
know how to do it I'm saying I could
show you one line well I was thinking
about taking a class literally one
three-hour class like penmanship like
can you show me that's right there on
YouTube I've been following some sick
people I don't I don't learn that I
could like that um
you should have somebody come on and
teach you Josh Wilson
what are you talking about you
portrait artist than anything I would
say yeah Immaculate portrait artist here
we go guys speaking to Josh Wolf
I'm just gonna say this right now
don't remember 90 of the episode while I
didn't tell you this while I was
watching it your brain's strong yeah
while I was watching me start losing my
mind on camera and I could feel it I
started feeling it at home when I was on
the typing when I was typing I started
feeling that head space again and I went
whoa the brain is so strong all I did
was think about how deep I was in it
and watching myself and I felt started
getting the bad trip again at home oh no
isn't that crazy like a week after yes
it was weird dude described us what you
were what was going on yo I did not
think that was gonna be that strong me
and Josh eat mushrooms on the podcast it
happens these were different
they were so different I didn't know you
I didn't know Marty ate them until Josh
was driving or when Jake was driving
Josh up and I went Marty so thank you so
much for not tripping and holding
together oh [ __ ] tripping right now
what I didn't know because another thing
my back that disc in my back really was
hurting that day so if you notice I
barely turned toward Marty because I
didn't want to move my hair we were
sitting next to each other yeah I didn't
want to move my hip that was weird so
the whole time I kept thinking about how
bad my back hurt yeah like the trip I
could see
like my muscles like how they were
nodded now they're actually see it yeah
like a commercial where's the pain yeah
red that's how I felt so during the
podcast you could kind of see me like
this because I'm trying to keep my
weight off my [ __ ] back and hip
because it was
it hurts so bad dude I like it focused
on was it and I'm trying to hold
conversation and laugh like yeah like
every breath was like it was it was like
my sciatica and my hip so it's like
shooting pain every time I moved so I
was trying to stay still but like be
part of the show and then the bad trip
hit then when I closed mine I started
seeing shooting quick patterns in and
out
rolling like pattern like like I
couldn't hold it together when I open my
eyes I was okay but then I started just
my head just
talking about stuff that wasn't going on
time is all over the place time was
everywhere and then Josh was talking
like
are you talking slow he was talking slow
and I thought it was me I might shoot in
my head
and I started melting and then I started
feeling the
I wish you should go away and as soon as
I said that I knew it was gonna be bad
because I
I need to be kind of part of the
conversation I need to be part of the
show we're on the show and I'm over here
not even giving a [ __ ] and I went that's
not good
it's not good bro I wish these were gone
and when we was gone and went oh bad
trip I started just like thinking [ __ ]
dude what did I just talk about did I
even bring it up am I doing a bad job
right that was the worst feeling of all
time
I wasn't tripping anywhere near I first
of all I should have never did that
because I was just like irresponsible
like as the producer no what the [ __ ]
you only ate a half yeah and it was spur
the moment I did not plan I'm doing it
the [ __ ] just looks so delicious it
really was good though when I looked at
the chew I'm like oh this is cute I'll
waste half oh this is a cute thing
because not like I'll even feel it guys
it took I was eat I had the [ __ ]
supplement vitamin looking pills they
wouldn't work it took so much to get
them to work so I'm like I'll eat this
just as a little piece of candy
damn near as soon as I ate it I felt
like hell minutes later and I was like
the cameras were already set up I kind
of ate it walking back to the table on
my final check through
but it made me right away I'm like
feeling paranoid like oh man the
camera's not running [ __ ] hope damn it
like I had to get up and check the
cameras earlier but then it could just
kind of turned into like my eyes on full
fisheye and just having that weird
disconnect from the normal like yup
you're you're hosting act be a host be a
host be a host you're hosting why aren't
you talking why aren't you talking are
you even centered is Josh talking did
you even talk about his show are we even
promoting his show right are you [ __ ]
up thank God Marty's here that's what my
brain kept doing me too basically
I was just like I felt like I just keep
your hands on the wheel be a host and
then but my perception watching the show
back
perfect it was fun it was [ __ ] fine
nothing in my head that was going out
nothing happened as I was watching I was
laughing
harder so they went away for a couple
minutes and then came back so strong I
was up to about 5 30 in the morning I
was staring at my ceiling for maybe
three and a half hours
had the most intense trip it was just as
intense
here's my seven gram trips where I'm
astral projecting whatever I'm right
here
but more inside my brain you wanted that
seven gram trip though you didn't know
what the [ __ ] you didn't I didn't know
that I felt so bad watching you back eat
that second one
and remember how many gummies I ate
before though yeah I ate all those
[ __ ] shrimp gummies like these are
fine I only have four or five of them
and I went how much are they half crab
Josh doesn't normally oh no no these
ones are new and as I'm in my bed
tripping I'm like Josh like three times
you went and then I got over my buddy
well I don't know if I just say his name
and I can't say it
who did he get these from because ah oh
bro I'm telling you the visuals and the
[ __ ] that I was having at my in my room
I did a complete mind erase restart like
I needed it bad I needed to restart my
head and I was like you're gonna do this
this and this and this when you wake up
you're gonna have some bomb ass news
what the [ __ ] happened the next morning
we can't talk about yet what the [ __ ]
biggest [ __ ] that's ever happened on the
show Ridiculous
by far
this is true this is [ __ ] facts two
minutes later remonetized yeah damn hop
on my computer is remonetized were you
able to get into a space where it was
the least comfortable like once you got
home and just weren't having the second
I got home tell me this blankets that
aren't that thick and backlighting it's
another world I put the blanket over my
head and pushed it out you know you like
make it tight with your feet and hold it
so there's some space
I sat like that for like two and a half
hours
looking at [ __ ] I don't want to get too
into it but
no I'll talk about that's fine
it's not so much I could see it's like
they were saying slightly evil [ __ ]
like why do you care about if you heard
someone do whatever the [ __ ] you want
and I was like what the [ __ ] I couldn't
see it
feels something right here your thoughts
you could but but a thing oh okay but
like if your face is coming out of my my
blanket
damn like your shirt damn like your
shirt but then they would move together
and make a face of something like the
Fabrics of my blanket I was like and I
would look away like what the [ __ ]
and as it's talking to me and I was like
you have no idea who you're talking to
bro I'm not selling out for [ __ ] good
try [ __ ] and then Rosie walked
in the room
damn
they're like saying you should do this
and do that I'm like
[ __ ] you but I was talking to them
without moving my mouth yeah you're I
was Dripping my balls off basically I
was [ __ ] they had like swindily greasy
energy
yes
yes one was a girl but it wasn't like a
gender I just felt that it was a woman
um
I've never had these feelings on
mushrooms and tripping
it's like these ones were so vivid and
deep that it like brought me to a
different part of this [ __ ] evil [ __ ]
that I've never experienced and like it
wasn't that it was evil it was more like
be selfish it was like throwing things
out like do whatever you want [ __ ]
people who cares if you heard someone's
feelings [ __ ] that company
what the [ __ ] a lot of you people
actually think like that yeah and then
as it was saying and I was talking to
him like do you realize who the [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] you're talking to get the
[ __ ] out of here and everyone's like get
the [ __ ] out of here told Rosie the
whole thing
she had a bad trip
when it was with OG and [ __ ] she told me
she was having a bad shape but we never
talked about like what was going on same
exact thing was talking to her saying
the same [ __ ] when I was so [ __ ] what
did it say ago
she goes what the [ __ ] that's what was
talking to me like it was like four
months ago
whenever you're trying to pull some
[ __ ] it's not gonna work we're out
there doing some weird swindling
spiritual [ __ ] whatever it is I don't
know if it's real or not another
dimension listening right now yeah if
you know the dimension watching this
[ __ ] first off like the video dick
second off hit that Bell [ __ ] not gonna
work bro I was broken poor did the trip
way worse once yes it was all [ __ ]
great after that I was like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm gonna work harder
I'ma do more
I'm gonna do this so maybe that was the
trip setting itself up to do get you to
do that maybe do because right after
that I took the blanket off my head but
[ __ ] this Rosie came down and watched
peaky blinders I'm sitting there like
this is the most intense
life and I'm tripping oh and they're
talking about the the uh no the the
episode it was was like a war battled
murder [ __ ] and I'm like that like in my
head I'm like
it's like in my head I'm like this is
the most intense show but in my head I'm
like separating it from me I'm like I
know I'm not there yeah this is just
true you can tap in what it would feel
like to be there
oh yeah almost like I could smell the
bar they're in man I was tripping and as
I'm sitting there I'm like
I can't wait to make my cult classic
movie it's gonna happen
and I'm sitting there thinking I can't
wait to walk out on like a Tonight Show
hey thanks for having me you smell good
like oh sorry and that's gonna be the
first thing I say like oh God I can't
wait I was just thinking of all these
things like cool I'm just gonna work
harder [ __ ] this whatever was trying to
talk to me and I remember I remember we
went [ __ ] you you know who I am like you
should pick the wrong person to try this
I like that feeling I liked I was like
get the [ __ ] away from me it's so weird
I'm talking about it but I talked about
it to rosion like Rosie I don't know I
was telling her about it the next
morning
then I got the text from you what the
[ __ ]
ing we'll talk about another time
and then I was like Rosie this is gonna
be a great day I'm gonna [ __ ] Crush
[ __ ] so there's some I don't know what
it was but I think I got tested last
night and I [ __ ] won
walked out logged into computer you're
remonetizing I scream my girls get the
[ __ ] out here she's like what what I'm
like who's monetized and it's like shut
the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up I look I go
in the back end 31.
there might be podcast fans that don't
understand the true significance of the
win the math it's not about the fact
that he is making money on this channel
that's the fact that they loud it we
went through so much
[ __ ] are you just fighting against
the grain so just that acknowledgment is
just it's yeah it's not even the money
yeah I just can't keep it no don't keep
it
I don't care it's when in actuality I
got recommended by an unage restricted
video yesterday that I can't even say
say the title I don't say the title
I just think it's funny don't say this
out I had another one you can bleep it
bleep it okay it's funny if I says it it
was one man standing behind one man and
there was a blanket in front of the guy
in the back over the guy's butt but the
pictures like this guys you can see he's
naked and there's a towel over his back
and there's a guy standing behind him
holding the towel bleep this and it says
real
versus
can I tell the difference
nice
on YouTube recommended to me on age
restraint on age restricted bleep the
parts because we will get age restricted
for that yeah
and that's the point that we're trying
to make that's the only that's when we
whine about YouTube that's the only
point that we're trying to make yeah I
was like yo just be fair guys this is I
mean we're just having fun but it was
the double Jello Channel sorry we're on
good graces at YouTube thank you so much
we're just saying that title I just said
well you bleeped
that sounds like a joke yeah
that sounds like a Porn Convention joke
and that's on YouTube recommended to me
on my homepage I lost considering how we
have to do this whole tiptoe around
every title we make for every video and
thumbnail my mom's video got age
restricted I got to lead off Instagram
all I did was say happy birthday to my
mom post a picture of her I got deleted
so anyway we're back in the good grace
that's why we're he was saying we're not
I'm not trying to complain we're talking
about like what a way because I logged
in that day and went no
I can't believe it you didn't like apply
for the [ __ ] they just no the night
before
I went and was like
let's see what these buttons do I click
monetization the button I went to the
thing and it says uneligible and went I
know yeah and then I went to the bottom
it says last day to apply something
something 2021 I went oh so nothing and
it had a transparent bar I said reapply
yeah right and I clicked in and pressed
I went
transparent bar clicked I just clicked
it out of just curiosity like yeah right
and it went
and says we will reevaluate and get back
to you within seven days woke up in the
morning was back should we apply for
that [ __ ] plaque
Marty stop don't say that I know I'm
probably just
building you up to [ __ ] let you down
no no no you're right
do they have a million subscriber
playing
yeah that's the next one that you get
one for no 500 no oh that's sad yeah I
know
oh my God
you got it done oh my God if I get that
black I'm gonna [ __ ] show put it
right next to the can't stop the other
one the one you made us
wow what I didn't think about the
plaques man can I get my little check
mark
you don't have it on the yellow oh man
no I don't they are cannabisists
for real YouTube You're about to get
you're good you're good though YouTube
Miss maybe the the owner of operations
or whatever you want to call it yeah
look at the link let's all bookmark this
episode cause
yeah but anyway mushroom demons thanks
for testing me and losing because I won
but you feel better the next morning I
felt so [ __ ] much better my hair my
head got cleaned out
but I just got cleaned out I'm not gonna
talk about everything but as I'm sitting
there going through every aspect of my
[ __ ] life I'm like all right what am
I lagging how can I fix this how can I
fix this heart
all right boom so I got a new trainer
I'm like this train is not gonna work
it's not gonna be it's gonna be a
[ __ ] plateau of some [ __ ] the
train I'm about to do is an ex Olympian
he's 60 years old and he's the most
ripped man I've ever seen in my [ __ ]
world that guy I'm gonna start training
with him nice yeah you got it he is
gonna be the one that gets me in [ __ ]
uh Mario Lopez shape you know what I
mean I don't care about being in shape
it's I'm gonna make
some piece of a [ __ ] fat guy is not
as marketable you you play the fat guy
and just yeah just a bit I mean a health
thing of course I'm talking about like
now it's different like yeah when it
comes to everything it's like dude
my uh your clothes will probably sell
more if it looked better on you fat [ __ ]
hey you're you're fat modeling your
clothes like hey man
[ __ ] you is my company and it works but
it'd be better if I was like yo Thomas
you're in great shape good job and I
would like to
not be [ __ ] shitty fat I'd be sick
you gotta be tired like that'd be tight
so that's when we get a new dream I was
thinking all that when I was a mushroom
like dude
stop you have the time just get it done
you always say like you cannot be making
money and be out of shape because you
have to get a trainer you have to take
care of it and I did
my trainer wasn't great
I got stuck in a rut with this guy it's
like anything though you got to find you
know a babysitter you go to find uh
anybody like you gotta test out a couple
days but I'm noticing like you're not
gonna give me to where I need I need to
get something else
uh at least I'm recognizing it now
because before but at least I'm going
like for what [ __ ] just stay the
same it's got to be really valuable with
time well spent I'm about to I'm I'll
just switch around get your days back
well I just did oh dude because I got my
kid a bus pass I've been doing this
Ariana oh
man I've been doing this episode
one kid at one school one kid at another
school another kid at another school so
now it's the one's going to the yeah
plus Sports all of them uh one of them's
going right to the bus stop and then the
Gym's right next to it so yeah I feel I
feel the same way the mushroom chip
didn't give me any of that but I still I
have the feeling of like man we got this
opportunity we got to be the best you
can be yes that's that's another thing
like
why not you gotta just step it up I've
done it before in life you gotta just
but this time it's got to just be
forever like yeah this is just the
change yeah so expect that from me yeah
because right now is the first time I
didn't clean my house I haven't cleaned
my house yet I have a [ __ ]
housekeeper that comes in because I'm
like yo while she's doing that I'm
hitting all my [ __ ] emails I'm
filming I'm coming back my house is
spotless Rosie we had in surgery like I
don't want to be [ __ ] doing [ __ ] I
don't have the time I came back like
yeah
because never in my life I mean I was
trying to help her do [ __ ] I felt so
like do you need help like wait Thomas
just chill the [ __ ] out
don't feel bad because I feel bad like
hey can you clean my stuff
it's a piece of [ __ ] no that's how I
always felt until I went I have 23 hours
of work today yeah you cannot [ __ ]
clean the house today and I
I have OCD [ __ ] so I hate having dirty
[ __ ] yeah but when I moved residence
Rosie is not the she's the opposite
whenever I cleaned Rosie's room when I
started dating hey can I just organize
your [ __ ] rooms I hate it it was a
typical girl's fashion room it's closed
everywhere please see our closet that's
uh that's how I want my life like I
needed to be [ __ ] organized walking
done American Psycho yeah that's how I
want to live my life minus killing
[ __ ] like I feel like I don't want to
just kill people yeah I just want to
chill but like I wake up every morning
and I do 1600 crunches like uh
he's that motivation let me just add in
and then halfway through I take two dabs
perfect like I'm at the level yeah I'm
at the time of my life where I'm like
dude
it's concentrating upping your [ __ ] yeah
getting [ __ ] better and making
everything better because I'm tired of
like
oh you want to go do this cool but bro
you're still out of shape what the [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] are you doing I I think
about this [ __ ] every day so I know
[ __ ] like come on Thomas like
come on man [ __ ] you man I'm harder on
myself all right so I'm trying so that's
something on your Consciousness it's the
worst thing especially when I keep
putting this [ __ ] off but now it's like
I have the time now I mean I don't have
the time but I'll make the time now
that's it I
thanks for the mushrooms Josh all right
thank you that [ __ ] really really worked
like it
like one of the fan questions was uh
what advice to your 18 year old self
don't put [ __ ] off like because it
transfers over to bills debt like it's a
habit forming thing and for me like
coming out of high school I was so
disciplined through basketball so
violently disciplined that I once I hit
20 and started smoking weed and [ __ ] I
was like all I earned a couple years of
[ __ ] just letting go of it don't do
it like
discipline that's not what we're saying
yeah no if you're gonna do that do that
but don't don't
feel like it's okay to let go of certain
disciplines because your life will
[ __ ] your subconscious that nagging
will never stop and you want to avoid
that if you don't have that nagging
who know who's gonna nag for you and
when it's not a nagging when you're
checking all the boxes and doing what
you need to do it's a boosting voice
it's uh like now you can relax because
you earned it voice I'm day four waking
up stretching drinking water making my
[ __ ] bed every [ __ ] morning right
when I wake up make the bed of chug
water and stretch never have I done that
before and I was like you know what [ __ ]
I'm gonna start today tomorrow will be
day four yeah
bucket in stretch this morning this
morning
I did I'm a creature routine and a good
night and a bad way I'm not I need
structure I can build the structure but
if you fit I let something slip out of
it it will remain out of it it can uh
like put myself in a position to have to
dig out of a hole for it in various
different ways in life Marty you text me
at 10 like yo video's done and I'm like
yo what's up because nothing been up
since six like [ __ ] that doesn't oh God
I'm saying like your routine you know
what you're doing you get up you get
your kids ready you drop them you come
back you know you start work you do this
Marty I wake up every day like this
what's gonna happen that's how it is I'm
like oh film day what do I do until then
I don't know I don't have a structure so
I started doing this I said like I'm
gonna wake up and drink water and make
the [ __ ] bed every time I walk in and
see the bed going oh good [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it's that simple it's
little wins like you're like 40 of them
a day come on man when you see those
disc blast fools on TV I could do that
just be that that's how I'm trying to
think of it like David Goggins was a fat
[ __ ] too he's not anymore you know so
I've it's not impossible I've seen this
[ __ ] yeah it's it's it's it's more of
just like life and I always say like oh
they made more money but I'm just it's
it's a I'm kidding but I'm also not
kidding that [ __ ] will help I'm not
kidding it's more of like bro I'm
[ __ ] over this [ __ ] and you're not
fat but you're you're definitely not
like no I want to be in shape like I was
doing kickboxing and [ __ ] with everybody
even if you're not you're skinny dude
like no I want to be rocked the [ __ ] out
like it's not it's for yourself it's not
so I can look in the mirror and [ __ ] so
I can go to sleep
good [ __ ] like you're [ __ ] upping it
cause like in a video game and you can
go up your character's attributes don't
tell me you never do you always up the
attributes that's how I feel like why
aren't I doing it to myself man this is
GTA
I'm doing everything but you could
easily do it yeah that's how I feel like
what the [ __ ]
and I see these fools Benjamin like dude
I want to be able to bench four
on page three again
just be like yeah nothing like why not
when I try to bench 240 the other day
and I went
I was so disappointed in my [ __ ] body
and myself like bro what I know it's a
lot of weight but for me
that's reps
the 16 year old me would I always say
that I asked this on Tick Tock and I'm
asking you guys leave it in the comments
right now would your 16 year old self
beat the [ __ ] out of your current self
[ __ ] no
oh you think you could [ __ ] your 16 year
old self up now
bro oh Marty's the only one on the earth
I didn't know how to kickbox them oh I'm
talking about shapewise
do you think your 60 year old shuffle
all I could do I could run forever from
you like I was like same but I was
strong
no I think she only would beat the dog
[ __ ] out of me right now I know way more
now than I did then I'm oh I'm not
talking about skills yeah I'm talking
about pure physical attribute do you
think like yeah yeah my six-year-old was
a little [ __ ] like mine wasn't yeah it
was a beast so that's why I asked people
like do you think your 16 year old
version would [ __ ] you up yeah like then
you need to get in the [ __ ] gym
that's how I feel like then you didn't
work out that's how I've been feeling
dude it sucks I had heart but I was for
real I had heart but I was frail that's
the name of my first stand-up I had
heart but I was frail sorry Mom please
stop yeah nah I got old man strength now
that's different though that's different
old man strength I won't get that [ __ ]
till I'm old like 60. I got it once I
hit that third kid you get it
pings in
everyone out there
all the younger dudes don't try to fight
a four-year-old man you need your ass
beat
for some reason our bones solidify once
we get like past 30. you just get it's
just something kicks in that it's like
nature wouldn't allow that a little man
strength yeah yeah it's true it's real
old men are scary [ __ ] kill you with
their hands I've had those moments I've
died by an old man Buffalo when I was a
kid
Jesus Christ
sorry I'm doing some water by the way
go listen to David Goggins we mentioned
David Goggins Buffalo native go listen
to can't hurt me is he a buffalo name oh
yeah I didn't know that I didn't know
that until I was an adult I wish I would
have known that I did not know that dude
yeah my uh first audible book I ever
listened to my favorite audiobook they
did it like a podcast him and his
it's his life story how he became the
toughest man alive
and has to do that like wrote it for him
his co-author they did it just like this
like you did the podcast exactly that
popped up in my show the other day
what's a my [ __ ] YouTube oh oh the uh
videos off yeah yeah that show was weak
this [ __ ] was weak I could do socks
you're such a better one now oh that for
sure for sure yeah I'm thinking about
making an online course dude put it out
with Malco yeah a video photo brand
design for you know when you're hot
YouTubers probably lighting the shirt
with a new pen
all right
new pens New Generation but it's not a
lighter okay it's not a [ __ ] lighter
I really did try to light that right now
with this
um
dude we're we're way out of traffic
today we try to keep it tight not
happening are you ready we're talking
about Josh Wolf I was way too [ __ ] up
that the mushrooms brought it out of me
and now I'm so [ __ ] up time was all
over the time was terrible time was
awful time was bad we there was a point
where me and Josh were having a side
conversation Marty had to cut it out of
the show
because me and Josh yeah cause me and
Josh Josh and I went Josh you know
you're talking to the mic right oh all
we hear is us talking over Jacobs
we're probably gonna cut that
and then there was a point where I'm
like
are you saying words I think that might
have been stuck in the I think that was
in the podcast
oh my god did you say English [ __ ]
because it sounded like you were
speaking some Ewok weird [ __ ] and I
think he was just mumbling
but there was a couple of times we had
to stop and cut it out because there was
just too much mumbling and jumbling
[ __ ] raw mushrooms we were on
mushrooms I didn't remember it was so
scary because we filmed on a Tuesday my
editing schedule is Hefty I don't get
back I don't Circle back to the episode
until Saturday and Sunday so I had
Wednesday Thursday Friday to really just
wonder what the [ __ ] was in that footage
that I was gonna find because I had no
clue it was a whirlwind I didn't
remember anything until I started
watching it back and then once I started
watching it I remembered my POV yep it's
me too the whole time and it was
completely different from reality
I only ate a half a chew
aggressively though was of true half of
the whole bar but it was only half but
it sent me though I was on the the brink
of Hostage of being a [ __ ] host dude
it was bad it was bad but hold on back
to that since we're way off track today
you ready
the Josh Wolf episode
guys when I was in Indiana we had a
couple come up
give us
artwork it was one was Marty's face
which is his profile picture and one was
my face like some dripping ass dope ass
picture with like a joint
he made a shirt came to the Indiana meet
and greet and gave his shirts right here
Marty bring it up across the screen his
Instagram name I'm sorry I can't
remember off the top of my head that's
his Instagram thank you so much for
making money made it Lenny made it oh
yeah it was I was like oh it's like a
Marty [ __ ] Lenny made it thank you Lenny
made it he made us some pretty sick ass
shirts guys he made me two and Marty too
so we have an extra one the only other
ones on Earth are in Marty's closet in
my closet and next they're gonna be in
your closet they're different sizes
if it doesn't fit you just keep it
one-on-one yeah you got you get what you
get with this mine's a large yeah so
there it is all right it's only another
size if it's too big probably for you
for mine just keep it all right
we're gonna give these away we're gonna
give them away I know we were gonna keep
them but [ __ ] if we have two and they're
like basically one of ones only we have
it only one other person in the world
has it [ __ ] dope and you guys are our
fans the solo episode we can do this
brand I don't really want to do this
during guests by the way guess hold on
we want to give [ __ ] away like nah we'll
do this during our solo episode so guys
we're starting it now this is the first
time we're doing it and I picked the
names
I went through the comments of the Josh
Wolf episode so you guys know on YouTube
comments up to the first thousand are
always answered back after that it
trickles down to like
40 a day basically we do like another
hour and lower we do them all to a
thousand then we do like half an hour to
an hour a day so we might miss yours but
it's not on purpose it's just we didn't
get to it in that hour it's as many
people as the entire theater at the
atmosphere show that you answer comments
to yes that's crazy yes Rocco does a
huge part portion of it but what a huge
portion of it now let's go that's eight
hours a day yeah so we don't have that
anymore so we're we're trying all right
so we went through the comments and I
was like you know what today I'm going
to pick top comments I'm gonna go
through the top comments and I'm gonna
pick two people
and you win so if you're watching this
I'll find your name please hit us up let
us know we'll get your information your
email you win the shirts we're just
going to give them to you shipping too
because I think it's really cool this is
Marty's idea shout out Lenny made a
shout out everybody making the cool fan
art I love that so much this I'm built
my career off doing fan art and to see
people making cool [ __ ] for us now it's
weird awesome it's weird it's odd when
people make sure you spend the time
wow it's so dope so sick people are
talented it's so cool yeah that's
another thing like you made this what to
have like a Halloween season I'm a
cyborg [ __ ] whatever it is it's sick
come on
um so the first person
we're gonna pick this is Corbin Murphy
all right Corbin Murphy this is you
It's a Mario logo with like a it's like
a hipster Mario that's his profile
picture that's you right there
um that's his comment uh he's just I
just picked one it's more of the top
comments than I went through I'm like
you know what super positive comment
there you go right there you went what's
the gist of his comment he says the fact
that he replied to every comment I have
last let you've replied to every comment
I've left in the past 50 episodes is
insane genuinely wish to work for you
one day
and officially we've been doing
dopasiola for four years straight on
YouTube
every week uploads for four years now so
we've answered
we've had over 800 000 comments I can
put the lifetime
one billion yeah we can't we can't
almost guys but we've answered back
probably 500 000.
it's a lot of comments man I spent six
hours a day
for a three and a half years straight I
just realized I could reply to my
Instagram DMS with quick little voice
messages and it's way [ __ ] I said
videos
people get hyped we're like hey what's
up man just won't let you know me yo
thank you so much man sorry I'm filming
right now but [ __ ] appreciate you and
then you just get back
all right
thanks man sorry I'm smoking a bowl real
quick thank you guys it's way more
personal
and I think people appreciate him or
just remember to put allow replay
because some people don't expect it
they're like yo I wanted to save it it's
just something like
you dm'd your favorite artists back yo
what's up man I'm making a song right
now but I appreciate you so much
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up you would lose your
mind and be so excited and that's why I
would do that chick it's like dude if I
do that make someone [ __ ] a day by
simply existing
let's [ __ ] do it so that right there
Corbin Murphy [ __ ] appreciate you so
thank you so much you win the shirt or
one of the shirts me or Marty whoever
replies first basically and if the size
matches that's my shirt you'll get you
just want to make sure hopefully it fits
if it doesn't
just like yeah put it on your wall or
something I don't know we might sign him
on the back oh no sorry we are going to
sign them yeah we are going to sign them
if we don't if we can't find a way to
sign it we'll sign something else and
send it with the shirt all right next
one majin420 wise one The Greatest Story
Time Mystery has just been solved Josh
and Jake are the best guests you've had
so far
dude I watched the clip where his son
revealed what happened you you can see
it Jake comes down what the [ __ ] he
comes from the back like no and he
really just just pops it out Josh you
could tell he's like you can see he
didn't know he was coming it says oh you
know I'm Josh's oldest son like just
wanna let you guys know something they
order the porn like oh no no way 15-year
missed our 10-year mystery solved
greatest porn debacle in American
history damn near
amazing you might have to bleep that
that might be a bad trigger words man
okay well we're in this edit Marty when
you're like that and you're editing go
bleep
cheek guys probably not the best
I snapshot the title I looked down did
you yeah I do that all the time for
everyone out there how do you remember
things so much I literally screenshot
things I look at the room you want to
know why I have a great memory visually
because I was so afraid of monsters and
[ __ ] when I was a kid
did you ever think a monster is gonna go
in your bed and grab your leg and you're
going underneath when you're walking
yeah not like to cut your ankle I wish I
was scared of Chucky so I always thought
like Chucky would be under there slice I
didn't get that visual until I saw a
hostile
ew ew then I thought that that mean I
wanted to travel and I was a teenager
but no I would do this I know a lot of
you do this too walk to the to the room
to the door where the lights at go
look what's all right all right if I
jump one two jump
I would visualize and go like that I
would do this
turn the light on off turn it back on
screenshot it every [ __ ] night so I
wouldn't eat [ __ ] and eventually got to
the point where I just go like this one
two three jump boom right in my bed
because I always knew like if you put
your ankle by that [ __ ] bed someone's
gonna slice your [ __ ] or a monster's
gonna grab your [ __ ] leg I was scared
as a kid
so that's hot I think that's why I got a
good memory doesn't help you got Howie
Mandel out there like literally doing
that [ __ ] in movies and stuff so what do
you mean little monsters oh yeah no
that's a good one good one yeah man I'm
not sure it was kind of little Mother's
dope I was afraid of Chucky yeah but no
for real that's I think that's what
helped my memory a lot I mean I remember
[ __ ] from I was a baby I had a great
memory but visually remembering like
right now ready
I can tell you what's in the room like
you're just when I do this it's just
physically to like all right you did it
like a screenshot but in reality you're
just like looking going okay I can place
everything in my head right now like
right now I could walk all the way the
car eyes closed because I like you know
you're you're doing some Daredevil [ __ ]
you see the [ __ ] vibrations and
whatever I'm not for real but I can I
remember certain things and like in
Franklin uh slo-mo drive like there's
certain moments in life that like
even in real time like slow-mo one time
in life that's happened to me only once
we almost got T-boned
and we're at a stoplight and the fool
just
came out of nowhere almost killed us
things I went hey hold on wait that
car's going weird
and then
my homie to stop for a second what
turned around went and that fool was
sliding sideways at us and it was in
slow motion I went
somehow went like this
and went around this like impossible
Miracle [ __ ] everyone looked at you like
do you guys saw the way that turned
like we all looked at each other like
was that a miracle
that was pretty crazy that's the only
time I saw something super slow motion
like it was realistically slow motion
where I could look around like what
yeah that's how I felt oh
my when I was referring to was the
[ __ ] white trash argument where I was
like shut up
is this really [ __ ] real this is what
I was thinking in the moment
was there a gun
on the cops
yeah that's your slow-mo moment a white
trash argument yeah it was so white
trash it became slo-mo it was
astonishing
seriously yeah she mean to tell me your
beard comes in all white trashy like
that hey man if you need to make fun of
me I'll just leave your radio show
but also
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now
that was the most wild [ __ ] you have
ever said in how many episodes are we in
that many I don't think I've ever heard
you say something more wild that I did
not expect okay I thought you were gonna
say like yeah no it was your time you
got that [ __ ] shotgun and these fools
rushed us no no a white trash argument
you felt so ignorant and not want to be
involved and I went yeah out of this
place literally it was like just so bad
the one it was just a really bad
argument that was like yeah crossed into
Springer territory and how bad it got
your family at least yeah okay yeah can
you take about talking about what
happened yeah yeah it was around the
whole incident at Ariana's birthday
party with the cops and all that and but
that's what the white trash thing was oh
yeah there were two black dudes that did
that though how is this my trash because
my oh because the way your family
reacted oh [ __ ] please tell me dude I'm
just going to leave that one alone oh no
see that's why I asked and then you're
like
yeah it was just
I was just
had never seen us turn on each other
before on your own family on your own
family yeah because of what your friends
did they turned on each other
that doesn't even make [ __ ] sense
a lot of [ __ ] doesn't make sense so okay
I get where the slow-mo happened it did
it was that bad I get it because that
doesn't make sense your homie did some
[ __ ] so your family beat to share of
each other
oh because they're your brothers yeah oh
there was a all tied in but
Buffalo the only place where two black
dudes are involved in directly white
trash family arguments
isn't that what it says when you're
going to the town Buffalo City of only
place where two black dudes can cause
white family trash arguments one of the
dudes is a raven but oh that's right
right sorry my bad my bad I only know
these people from the stories
the only place where ethnic people could
cause the only place on Earth with no
Mexicans Buffalo New York this is man
this is all I know is [ __ ] that you tell
me yeah so I'm just picking [ __ ] from
other episodes
I was thinking how epic our Vlog would
be if you we ever did do like a meet and
greet there oh a meet and greet meat you
want to go Vlog no I don't I don't want
to you did that already yeah you have
those videos and you send them to me all
the time they're ghetto with [ __ ] yeah
those are good enough Vlogs yeah but
hold on not something I want to do if we
didn't meet and greet we should do a
meet greet there one day first off
second
why trash argument made you [ __ ]
slow-mo this is the craziest [ __ ] I
can't wait to tell Rosie tonight
I'm gonna the second I get the normal
you know what Marty said today it's
traumatizer I do that every time I get
back I'm like you want to know what the
[ __ ] happened today every time we do a
show I tell them like yo Mark said some
[ __ ]
because
who the [ __ ] else am I to tell right
away I'm like yo
get your watch Monday like no Mario I
can't believe it I can't wait to get
that I'm gonna [ __ ] have someone tag
that on the thing of Buffalo welcome to
Buffalo
we need a bigger sign here hold on yeah
hold on there's the papers
yo this wasn't an hour and a half bmari
looked at somebody let's keep it tight
it's midnight
it is 12 30 on the dot yeah I'm sorry
we've been here for a while also this
was [ __ ] awesome yeah we needed this
after that last episode
oh we need to reset I forgot what I felt
like to do a normal episode yeah also I
will never do psychedelics on the show
anymore yeah I'm gonna say that done
maybe even lightly drink if we go on
drink champ type [ __ ] other than that I
just stay on point I'm trying to become
[ __ ] late night talk show
[ __ ] at this point because this
the other day when I nailed that Adder
to go I could do this on TV one day
remember I nailed it yeah it was so
pretty close oh my I was so proud even
though I was talking about my dick it
was the manscape diameter with that
sounded so professional
I love this show we could do whatever we
want and YouTube guidelines
but I love this show yeah the fact that
we can yeah
um
we can talk about the Spotify too
they're showing yeah I think I think so
[ __ ] official right now right
now you can go to Spotify officially
partner with Spotify go use your podcast
you know that but
they may or may not have given your
[ __ ] friend over here the dope
is Yola Story Time Channel
[Music]
no age restriction no [ __ ] censorship
I got video you can go watch Story Time
videos go type in Spotify dopizziola
you may or may not see me pop the [ __ ]
up dope is yellow story time
is a channel on Spotify now guys that's
[ __ ] Channel we're still gonna change
the artwork make it a little different
but right now it's up go listen leave
some reviews please appreciate it leave
those five star [ __ ] help me out
we're smoking weed on Spotify season one
I have a 30 pack in one of the episodes
I left it there just to be like
let's just leave it and don't say a word
I think it'd be funny and that was like
8 000 comments of people like this full
didn't even mention this packs I put a I
put a basket and I put like 25 pounds
right there and I just left it like yeah
it was talk right here I thought it was
funny instead of this bush tree in the
shot it was all packs yeah
I'm putting that [ __ ] on Spotify can
you imagine not even that like what if
we gain other fans that never seen any
of our stuff of course
butterfly is a big platform just keep
making this community bigger and it's
like yeah thank you Spotify for just
letting you be us and thank you to
everyone thank you no questions or
verifying Marty drastic graphics music
page without even asking come on blue
check mark Marty oh come on
it's too dope it's too sick it's awesome
but also yeah you can watch dope as your
story time series uh season four is on
there we're gonna go with three two one
I could see Spotify becoming a playlist
for like the explicit version of fill in
the blank that'd be great and just not
have to worry about it
but that deal is gone I mean it's done
so thank you very much and uh we're
getting down to it a little bit I think
we can talk about it we did the van
giveaway
um one more thing are they gonna be live
by the time where this episode's out
no no
so just because this episode's out we're
gonna talk about it we you guys saw the
dope as usual bongs with prism glass we
got some sick ass bongs coming out just
check our Instagram we'll let you guys
know when they're coming out but dope as
usual podcast.com that's going to have
everything we have a bunch of different
sizes a bunch of different colors it's
super cool all right we're not saying go
buy them but if you go check them out
you haven't buy them it's all good learn
more learn more yes thank you learn more
at the dopes usualpodcast.com or dope as
usualpodcast.com coming up very soon
next week essential things are high
quality they're those they're made in
USA they don't they're portable they're
easy to clean they're customizable
different sizes different colors I'm
excited I'm excited these are sick
because it's not just like oh we got our
own like a class out now it's like
they're different they're actually way
better than probably what you got like
you're gonna be like well everyone
that's walking goes whoa and I'm like
[ __ ] that's what I want to hear [ __ ]
yeah dude they're cool they're they're
they twist off so you they're so much
easier to clean and I didn't think about
until we didn't go oh
ugly this [ __ ] five seconds Jake Wolfe
was like astonishing no he was that's
true that's true but yeah those are not
going to be live by the time this
episode's out but it's Monday right now
check tomorrow probably this coming week
yeah I would say this coming week yeah
and then before we get out of here can
we talk about one more piece of
information
that New York one wow we can say yeah
I'm talking about it it's heavily
heavily heavily in the works like as
much in the works as it can I don't care
if I gotta fly back I'll do it yeah okay
finally here
it's finally [ __ ] here all right it's
finally happening I fully intend on
trying to make this man go I don't think
I can smoke anymore and go all right he
passed that torch then I am the official
get people too [ __ ] up on podcast guy
now pass it over this is weird to be a
part of this no I'm not saying that's
that's what's gonna happen I'm not
saying I'm gonna take your spot no I'm
doing my own channel you're [ __ ] I'm
saying like metaphysically yeah like yes
you could do it you start doing it to
people you win
you know what [ __ ] I'm going on
Joey Diaz is [ __ ] they're going on D
as a show all right I don't know what
else to say I was to say podcast show
not the show we're gonna we're finally
making it happen Okay I can't [ __ ]
wait podcast swap
whatever he's in L.A coming on the dope
as usual podcast but next week when I'm
in uh New York I spoke supposed to be
set up fully done I hope it goes through
and if not I'll fly back out there on
the date that does work but already he
said they're like yeah gotta find the
date
yo finally happening guys Joey Diaz and
I will be in the same room smoking
[ __ ] monsters together I can't
[ __ ] wait what a day oh this room is
gonna be full of fox sweat smoke
laughs
my best case scenario you guys you go
out there you do it you guys make a
connection he comes out here we have an
epic all-time episode yeah come through
come on guys thank you for making this
all possible thank you come on shout out
to Malcolm media for making this happen
finally go on the Joey Diaz show get out
of here crazy I'm excited the originator
somebody that I listen to that helped me
get through Michael come up when I first
met you that's all you you that's one of
the people you were talking about like
the direction you were taking oh a
motivational [ __ ]
inadvertently motivational Yeah by your
like attitude hi [ __ ] you follow
on Twitter yeah that's the most positive
guy ever yeah I'm not on Twitter a lot
but I do follow him on Twitter go
outside and have a great day and crush
it
[Laughter]
oh it's engine with a [ __ ]
the iron cheek there you go iron cheeks
got the best Twitter
um it's finally happening guys so
excited for the Joey Diaz podcast
come on epic epic as hell so
so cool and shout out to that kid when
you when we said epic reminded me in the
video shout out to the kid I ran past
you in the airport as you were filming
so you're a legend oh I've never missed
my flight
more epic you ready that kid made my
[ __ ] dance like dude good timing I
was about to start you were like what's
up everybody
oh you recorded it
I just thought it was funny I'm like yo
you caught me right when I was about to
start bro good [ __ ] and it was dope I'm
gonna miss my flight
did I tell you what happened after
mm-hmm I did yeah two seconds later
two seconds later over Trent's shoulders
as he's filming I look and I go oh my
God is that Anthony Michael Hall and it
was and
as I went oh hey what's up YouTube while
I'm doing the intro you'll see me do
this
I looked over because I went and I
finished my engine like yo that's
Anthony Michael three times I'm doing an
intro and some of my favorite people
walk by me while I'm doing a joke last
time I was doing intro in Hollywood
Jonah Hill walks by me to get some [ __ ]
at this weed store or whatever you see
people and I was like that yeah as I was
filming I went [ __ ] it's Jonah Hill
right there but I'm doing an intro bro
I'm not gonna stop my intro to go say hi
I'm filming and you walk my way come on
man [ __ ] and by the time I turned around
he was already inside and then [ __ ]
Bill Burr I was like off
and then Andy Michael Hall if you don't
know Michael Hall is you guys you
youngins might notice the kid with the
glasses like this with the joy the meme
that you see everywhere that's from
Breakfast Club he's the kid from
Breakfast Club and uh Edward
Scissorhands he's the [ __ ] boyfriend
from Edward Scissorhands
there and he's also the guy from uh Come
on Anthony Michael Hall What's that show
can you look it up that show from Fox he
was super popular on he was like the
Vision man he had a cane and a limp
was the show called Dead Zone yeah
Anthony Michael Hall I'm such a fan of
him breakfast club and [ __ ] so I was
like yo
it's gonna be a good trip okay [ __ ]
Anthony Michael Hall from Breakfast Club
walking by that kid made my day let's do
it so that's how that all of that
happened in six [ __ ] seconds
literally as that kid walked by all
right I looked Patrick
holy [ __ ] you're old now Anthony Michael
Anthony Michael Hall you're old
it was weird guys thank you so much for
being here Marty and I gotta get going
because he's got an hour drive in the
dark
and I mean I don't but I get out of here
too Rosie's waiting
um we're chilling guys we're hanging out
Rocco did you fall asleep
Rocco just got back from him they're
doing a photo shoot for push tree today
then he came over here sat through the
podcast doing all the comments right now
thank you very much guys thank you so
much for being here what a what an
awesome episode I don't even know what
to call it but what a lot of wins a lot
of good things a lot of self-reflection
and growth
yeah you hear that Dr Phil we can hang
out with you don't worry we can talk we
can talk about sex self flexible
the way Dr Phil talks is the way uh Ryan
Reynolds talks in his Forrest Gump voice
well I'll just look like that's how I
feared Dr Phil like you sound like a
like a sophisticated Forrest Gump that's
how I always I always hear his accent
anyway
um yeah that's it
Dr Phil don't worry man
because we were talking about the other
day like yo we can do mushrooms get
shit-faced
but we also had Dr Drew on the show yeah
we gotta go to Ray good variety yeah
good variety of uh streams of different
people coming in and as soon as I start
not doing mushrooms on the show which
I'm not gonna do anymore
we can start getting Dr Phil's all right
malca Obama
yo isn't it kind of crazy though no not
imagine what season because I never
thought about I went
that'd be an interesting interview to
interview next president
crazy
got Elon Musk to hit the joint yeah I'm
gonna get Obama to hit the joint bro oh
that's possible that's on the list Obama
you're on our podcast guest list come
through come through don't bring no
secret security because they can't no no
because they need a hot box and they're
gonna blow Sally Hank Hill and [ __ ] like
Obama's boxing out yo I think I think
Barack Obama would smoke a join with us
man I'm gonna be honest
I see bright future for the show and I
think that's sustainable
we need goals that's what you said at
the start I think it's obtainable
and it's so crazy to say that like
then we just do wakey Bake videos like
yeah I did man [ __ ] you
do we still do I can make videos
but it's crazy it's crazy thinking like
the first pictures I cut up hot dogs and
put ketchup for blood and I redid the
movie scene
and then I just were like why don't you
do this with nugs
that's how this started yeah here we are
Obama
toys to make
to make I still have your Spider-Man
um all right I think I think it's good
we're gonna get out of here man we never
really finished the joint oh mid I mean
we never really finished the episode mid
joint with us that's the last one that's
why
guys thank you so much for being here
really appreciate it this has been a
very fun episode a lot of a lot of stuff
a lot of stuff going on but thank you so
much if you haven't already if you're in
the chat if you're watching drop a like
if you're on the TV and you can't really
drop a like go on your phone and drop a
like that would be awesome we really
appreciate it above all just tell a
friend tell a friend to watch this
episode a little looser a little more
rant City but I like this [ __ ] this is
our ketchup episodes guys so thank you
for being here Marty got anything else
you want to talk about
I'm just appreciative thank you guys
that's a another fun episode it's
happening and checking in re-wrapping
wrapping up getting the [ __ ] to it
you paused I was like oh this is
philosophy philosophical I'm just
grateful like I know this is good that
was good that was good it is maybe we
can have someone cut it like the outro
well you got anything he'll say just
happy to be here man thanks the
different shirts and bills shirts and
hats
backgrounds of that to over here that'd
be kind of sick
that'd be kind of sick there you go I
want to build like a little clip thing
before you get out here because the dope
is yellow [ __ ] turns 10 next month I
think I might do a little clip of it
like highlight reel yeah it'd be cool
yeah but guys thank you for being here
once again appreciate you this has been
the dope as usual podcast we're here to
talk about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between today was a whole lot of in
between
a little bit of drug not a whole lot of
drugs and accomplishments thank you guys
so much for being here really appreciate
you guys be safe driving be safe
wherever you're at if you're at work the
shift will be over if you're at school
school ends thank you guys so much for
being here have a dope ass day
oh
I should have eaten eaten food
I feel a little dizzy
[Music]